actually in here has a last 700 million
mile problem that's the problem so
seventy percent of India is actually a
student so clearly when the economy
grows it doesn't necessarily lead to
prosperity for the seventy percent of
India's population I think the way
forward would be not to only focus on
economic growth but also see how social
innovation can have a place in
delivering social services and here I
think social entrepreneurs sometimes
offer solutions that can deliver for
example health to large number of people
literacy to hundreds of millions of
people and I think those social
innovations have to be looked at both by
the government and the corporate sector
and that's the way to spread that the
economic wealth and well-being to the
rest of the country thank you